oh
à
des notes résonnent au château de
l'agent drenière ici une poignée de
stagiaires apprend les bases du show
mios le champ bouddhique traditionnel
japonais maîtrise du corps et contrôle
du souffle pour cet art liturgique de
plus de 3000 ans et il faut bien
s'adapter aux partitions particulière de
ce chant très intéressant par rapport
aux méthodes européenne puisque là c'est
que dans le ressenti on suit le
mouvement et on s'harmonisent
voilà s'est laissé porter en fait parce
qu'il y est
c'est inconscient et
il faut rester éveillé en fait voilà
personne et où tout est dans la
perception et ses yeux center a là un
champ qui vient de l'intérieur et plus
précisément du à la un centre
énergétique situé dans le ventre des
morceaux liturgie qui peuvent résonner
ont chacun
[Musique]
identity japanese mais je ne veux pas
juste enseigné de la musique japonaise
comme quelque chose d'exotique
d'oriental je veux partager et partagé
est un mot léger mais je veux partager
quelque chose d'universel quelque chose
que tout le monde possède date n'y aura
donc à partir de ça je vais faire en
fait une calligraphie puis je vais
montrer le lien avec la peinture à
chaque début de cours le calligraphe
fait une démonstration à ses élèves
au delà de la maîtrise du trait et des
caractères l'idée est de travailler en
pleine conscience dans la tradition zen
c'est à dire dans un silence respectueux
du broyage de l'encré de chine solide à
l'application sur le papier il ya une
direction dans la dans l'art du trait et
de l'espace la direction c'est la beauté
l'harmonie
[Musique]
le silence parce qu'en fait c'est une
peinture très silencieuse et on apprend
en s'imprégnant des calligraphies que
l'on voit des calligraphies que l'on
rencontre c'est une imprégnation une
passion pour la calligraphie que la
nonne partagés avec m taisen deshimaru
l'homme à l'origine du temple
[Musique]